denis re años nunca pudo escuchar con la
voz de su hija elianis la canción que
ésta le había escrito la joven de 17
años fue la primera víctima de un
depredador sexual que sembró el terror y
el luto en la pequeña localidad de la
misión en el oeste de venezuela a
finales de febrero yo sé que mi hijo
voltea y dice tenía el método muerto
la encontraron muertas y en pantalla de
tyc sin ropa de espalda boca abajo
eso fue horrible horrible yo sentí que
me iba porque me estaba arrancando el
pecho
edward list falcón de 20 años dejó su
casa para ir al gimnasio y nunca regresó
ambas jóvenes venezolanas fueron
víctimas de feminicidios por el mismo
hombre que fue detenido luego de ser
delatado por su esposa pero el dolor y
el miedo persisten en la localidad
siento que se me vino el mundo de sino
por qué
no estaban guste en angus te pueden
esperando la noticia d
y entonces llegan y dicen no encontraron
a una niña muerta
en este medio no pensé en mi hija
en la última semana de febrero se
conocieron 5 feminicidios en lo que va
de año más de 51 mujeres han sido
asesinadas en venezuela unas alarmantes
cifras que han llevado al parlamento a
aprobar una reforma de ley sobre el
derecho de las mujeres a llevar una vida
libre de violencias
en la misión decenas de mujeres rompen
con el miedo y se entrenan en la defensa
personal o como no cualquier cosa que
sirva para no ser víctimas de una
violencia es bueno durante el 2020 al
menos 256 mujeres fueron asesinadas la
mayoría de las víctimas tenían entre 16
y 40 años una pandemia en la sombra la
brutal violencia contra las mujeres una
lacra que asola toda américa latina una
de las regiones más letales para las
mujeres